Hey guys!
Ready to learn to draw me?
Okay, grab your mighty pen ultimate or just a regular pencil; that works, too.
First, let's draw my head.
You know, ears.
Eyes.
Mouth.
Stuff like that.
Then, my neck.
I need that.
It holds my head up!
Now, let's draw my body.
Don't forget the "D" for Drew!
Two arms.
With my mighty pen ultimate in one hand, of course!
Two legs.
Kangaroo legs?
No way!
Drew legs!
Okay, now I need my superhero cape!
In my latest adventure, I save a unicorn.
Let's draw a unicorn horn!
Wings, even though that would make me a pegacorn or an alicorn.
Hey! I just think wings are cool, ok?
Finally, let's draw a unicorn laser shooting out of my magical unicorn horn.
Yeah!
Take that, bad guys!
Anyways, that's how you draw me!